ERIC KOLEDA: Hi, and welcome to
another episode of Google
Apps Script Office Hours.
I am Eric Koleda, and with
me today we have Jan.
And we are both on the
Apps Script devrel
team, Developer Relations.
And we hold these weekly office
hours to give you
updates on Apps Script
and answer any
questions you guys have.
So let's get started.
So I think we're going to start
with the release notes
for the last release
of the Apps Script
that we pushed out.
And do you want to cover this?
JAN KLEINERT: Sure.
So--
and you can find these
from developers.googl
e.com/apps-script.
There's release notes
linked there.
So this was from July 26.
And we made some improvements,
and we're actually continuing
to make more-- so you will see
more of these come out in the
near future--
to improve the speed of handling
large batches of data
in ScriptDb.
So when you're using say, batch,
we are trying to speed
up the processing in saving
those large batches of data.
And we've made some
progress there.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah, and if you
haven't used ScriptDb yet,
that's the new storage solution
built into Apps
Script, which is a JavaScript
object store, and it's easily
and simply accessible from right
in the script itself.
So if you haven't played
around with
that yet, take a look.
It's getting faster
by the day.
JAN KLEINERT: Yes.
Definitely.
Also, One of the script
templates that show up on the
welcome screen when you open
up script.google.com, we've
fixed an error in the Gmail
script template.
So if you've been having some
unexpected results from that
one, that's fixed now.
Also, there was an issue with
ScriptDb where sometimes if
you were setting an object
that had an empty--
that's causing errors, that's
been fixed now as well.
ERIC KOLEDA: And was that also
related to project properties?
JAN KLEINERT: Somewhat
related.
So the issues with project
properties for empty property
keys was fixed slightly
before this.
So that's resolved now, too.
We also added support for chat
within the script editor.
So now, if you're collaborating
with somebody
else, so if you and someone else
or multiple people are
editing a script, you'll notice
on the right-hand side,
there will be a panel where you
can chat with the other
collaborators who are currently
active on that script.
So that's pretty exciting.
So it's similar to the chat that
you would see if you're
in a document or spreadsheet,
you can do
that now in your scripts.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
And that's one of the great
things about scripts is that
since the editor and all the
code is hosted on Google
servers, collaborating between
different people writing
scripts is really simple.
And now with the chat, you can
make sure that you guys are--
people are synced
up when they're
working on a script together.
JAN KLEINERT: It makes
things a lot faster.
So there was an issue where,
for a short period of time,
scripts were not being copied
when you copied a site.
And that's resolved now.
So now, when you copy a site,
as expected, the scripts
associated with the original
site will come with it.
We also added autocomplete
for libraries.
So if you have a library
included in development mode,
autocomplete will work
for that library now.
So we added that feature, which
should make it much
simpler to develop against
your own libraries before
you're ready to make them
out there for the world.
ERIC KOLEDA: Because in
libraries, in general, you're
creating versions of your
library that are stable.
And when you're using a library,
you pick a version.
But when you flip on development
mode, now all of a
sudden you're using the latest
code, even if it's
not safe to a version.
And when you're building new
features in libraries and
testing them out, this makes
it a little easier.
JAN KLEINERT: For sure.
There was a problem
with set value and
the date picker widget.
That's been fixed now.
We also added remove methods
to the UI instance.
So now you can remove widgets,
such as panels or other
elements, from your
UI instance.
That should help you clean
up a lot on some of these
interfaces.
Instead of just having to hide
everything, you can actually
remove them now.
So that's great, a
long time coming.
We also added support for
Google Analytics via the
Analytics service.
I think I gave a teaser
on this last week.
But it's there now, the
documentation there.
And then two things that we just
added actually since then
that we haven't quite added
to the release notes yet.
But we have added updated
documentation for
the BigQuery service.
And also, yesterday, we added
support for version 1.5 of the
prediction API.
So those are all there
under the Google
API services section.
They are all the ones that you
have to enable first on the
API console.
But those are all there now.
ERIC KOLEDA: I think in general,
those services in
Apps Script mirror very closely
the services that you
would use outside
of Apps Script.
Right?
JAN KLEINERT: That's correct.
They're very similar.
[? ERIC KOLEDA: Introducing ?]
them directly via the Java
library or the Python library.
Basically, if you've already
been using some of these other
Google services in different
code you've written, you can
actually use them, very, very
similar methods and use cases
inside of Apps Script now.
JAN KLEINERT: So I think that's
it for release notes.
ERIC KOLEDA: So I know we have
some people in the hangout, or
at least one person here
in the hangout.
Hey, Josh, you want to join
back in and chat?
JOSH: Yeah.
Hello.
ERIC KOLEDA: Hi.
JOSH: Thank you.
Some exciting features
coming along.
I'm going to keep Bill's
feet to the fire.
If you don't know the history
of this, I came to these
first, and he came.
And he is actually
a developer.
I'm just a wannabe and right
now, a funder of developers.
And so I like to kind of
know what's going on.
So one of the things I'd like
to do, I have a really old
version of a CRM, GoldMine.
And it's about 10 years old now,
and it's limping along.
And I built kind of another silo
doing something related
to customer management
in spreadsheets.
And I have done a lot of
reporting on that, and I did a
lot of pivot tables and things
for reports, really wonky
stuff until I saw GAS
and what it can do.
Now I'm starting to think
that I want to move
my data into ScriptDb.
I'm looking at about a half a
million records and probably
35 attributes of each record,
so a healthy amount of data.
My concern is if I move totally
into the GAS ScriptDb
world, I've built a lot of
reports that really require
this data be in spreadsheets.
I mean, I only know how to
build reports off of
spreadsheets.
And I have done some kludgy
stuff to make it work, but it
works right now.
Would it be possible to store
my data in ScriptDb and
automatically pull it out once
a day into spreadsheets and
still have all the reporting
that I currently have?
JAN KLEINERT: Possibly--
and you're talking about
Google spreadsheets?
Is that right?
JOSH: Yeah.
JAN KLEINERT: OK.
So if you have about a half a
million records, I'm guessing
that you have more than
one spreadsheet, yes?
JOSH: Well, actually, so I have
two different kind of
silos right now.
And one's going to be managing
GoldMine and doesn't have any
reporting, and it's
really outdated.
And the other one
is just a whole
different set of records.
But yeah, actually,
I'm sorry, it is.
Both silos are about a half a
million, so maybe together
there would be some overlap.
So right now, I really do--
I only knew how to--
you can only pull 50
imports at a time.
So because I have that half a
million spread out amongst 70
branches, what I had to do was
create container pages.
So there's a spreadsheet with a
data page, and it could have
anywhere from 8 to
15,000 records.
I create pivot tables,
summaries of
that using pivot tables.
And I have about four important
summaries per each
one of the 70 spreadsheets.
Because I can't pull 70 times
4 into a grand total sheet,
what I did is create data
pages which pull four
summaries down into one page.
And now I've created
just one pull for
that, one import range.
And I know I'm not at GAS
world a little bit,
but it all ties back.
And then from there, so I have
one data page for each of the
70 branches.
I then, from there, break my
70 branches into three
regions, and I pull
down a third of 70
into a summary page.
So I keep summarizing
summary pages.
And believe it or not,
it's crazy, but it's
working right now.
It's not very elegant.
It's not very efficient, but
it's pretty impressive in its
inelegance.
But I can't lose
that right now.
I can't change the tire while
the car is rolling right now.
But I definitely think
that ScriptDb--
first of all, tell me it can
handle the volume of data that
have, right?
ERIC KOLEDA: Well, that was
one of the things that I
wanted to look into.
Because I know we do publish a
limit on how much data can be
stored in a ScriptDB.
JAN KLEINERT: So I think there
are limits on certain things.
So there's limits on the number
of records you can get
back in a single query, which
is not the same as saying--
because I think you get
50,000 records back
in one single query.
That doesn't mean you can
only store 50,000
records in the db.
You can just only get a
50,000-item snapshot at any
given time.
But there are some limitations,
I think, on the
size of the item.
But I don't know that we have
a larger aggregate limit on
the total size of
the database.
ERIC KOLEDA: I thought I
heard that discussed.
Yeah, I think we would have
to check that, though.
And the thing is that it's a
little difficult to calculate
it that is there, if I remember
that limit correctly,
that there is one that
exists because--
JAN KLEINERT: It's a
size limitation.
It's some number of--
ERIC KOLEDA: Megabytes,
gigabytes or something.
JAN KLEINERT: Yeah.
I think it might be
some small number
of hundreds of megabytes.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah, I think
that sounds right.
JAN KLEINERT: It's actually in
the documentation in the FAQ
section for ScriptDb.
ERIC KOLEDA: But it's not number
of entries and number
of attributes.
It really depends on how much
data is in those entries and
attributes.
So it can be a little difficult
to calculate.
I would say half a million and
times some 30 attributes or
something like that, you're
probably getting
maybe in the range.
We would have to do some number
crunching, I guess, to
figure that out.
JOSH: So at that point,
i'll just become, is
it efficient enough?
I mean, is it fast enough?
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
Or can you fit it all.
Right?
JOSH: Well, that is the
first question.
And then if I can fit it
all, is it reasonable?
I mean, is it working
with that volume?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
JAN KLEINERT: --between
interacting with the
spreadsheet service to basically
pull data from
ScriptDb and stick it
into spreadsheets.
And you can do some optimizing
there to save the data to the
spreadsheet in the most
efficient way.
If you have tons and tons and
tons of data, and you're doing
this all at once, we do also
have a script execution time
limit, so where any single
execution of a script can only
run for six minutes.
You--
I am just guessing off
the top of my head.
If you are trying to put a half
a million records into
the spreadsheet, it's probably
going to run into that limit.
So you would have to invoke
some sort of batching or
chunking of those right
spreadsheets.
JOSH: I'm not going to put
half a million in any one
spreadsheet because of the same
problem I have right now.
The spreadsheets themselves
cannot
handle it, forget ScriptDb.
So what I'm imagining is
keeping the exact same
spreadsheet structure that
I have right now and just
populating those spreadsheets
with
automatic pulls from ScriptDb.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
It certainly, I think, is
a possible solution.
I was actually thinking about
something similar today where
you keep your data in ScriptDb,
and then you output
segments of it to spreadsheets
to expose
the data to a person.
Because there's no
UI for ScriptDb.
You can't browse around it.
So you could use a spreadsheet
as a way to expose the data to
humans, or, in your case, maybe
expose it to all these
other processes you
have set up.
JOSH: Wow.
I'm flattered.
I'm having similar
thoughts to--
[LAUGHTER]
JOSH: Because people can work
with spreadsheets, right?
They can work with--
well, I was going to say they
could work with pivot tables,
but actually most
people don't.
Since I started working, I'm
like, wow, I needed to learn
this a long time ago, but they
have their limitations too.
ERIC KOLEDA: And I think, in
past hangouts, you've come and
asked about data storage
options.
I remember that's a topic
that's come up before.
And the one thing I would say
about ScriptDb, the thing that
makes it different and maybe
not appropriate, depending
upon all of your use cases,
is that it's not about
aggregation.
You cannot say, give me the sum
of all of these fields or
do accounts.
It's not a relational database
that gives you that kind of
aggregation ability.
And it sounds like that's what
you're using pivot tables for.
So if you're trying to take
large amounts of data and
compress it into summaries, you
cannot do that natively
inside ScriptDb.
You would have to either do the
math in code, export it to
a spreadsheet and have the pivot
table do it, et cetera.
Versus there are other data
storage solutions like the
Fusion Tables that do
allow for creating
views-on data that--
summaries and such--
or relational databases.
So if a lot of what you are
doing or all of what you are
doing is trying to create
summaries from large amounts
of data, then maybe
ScriptDb doesn't
provide you as much value.
I think ScriptDb is where you
have a lot of people that are
going to open a record, edit
a record, save a record.
Those records are complex
objects and maybe link to each
other, and there are
different types.
I think when you're more focused
on an individual
entity instead of the summaries,
that could be a
better place for ScriptDb.
But I think it depends really on
some of your use cases, but
that's just something to keep
in mind is that ScriptDb
itself is never going to be able
to give you a total of
some field across all
your entities.
You'll have to do that
math on your own.
JOSH: OK.
And one last more specific
question.
ScriptDb, last I knew, didn't
handle dates very natively.
Is that in the works?
Because that would be
a huge impediment.
JAN KLEINERT: That is
still the case.
So you can't save the native
JavaScript date object.
Instead, you can either save a
string representation of it,
or if you're actually going
to be doing some sort of
arithmetic or stuff,
then you can
save the numeric timestamp.
But yes, that is still a
limitation that we hope to not
have as a limitation in the
future, but currently it is.
ERIC KOLEDA: Dates are
one of those things
that are tricky, right?
And I think one of the engineers
brought it up when
he was talking about it.
Like, if you create the date
and you're on Eastern time,
and then what if you try to read
it again, and now you're
on Pacific time?
It gets complicated where when
you save a timestamp, that
timestamp is true everywhere.
It's the number in milliseconds
since 1970.
And that's going to be
true no matter where
you are in the world.
So I think it's simpler this
way, but it definitely
requires a little
bit more work.
And I think we're looking at
ways to make it easier to use
but without causing
all sorts of weird
confusion around time zones.
JOSH: OK.
Thank you.
ERIC KOLEDA: So we have Jim
joining the interim.
Are you there, Jim?
JAN KLEINERT: I think he
might be on mute here.
But we do have several questions
on the moderator
page that we can jump over
to if you'd like.
ERIC KOLEDA: So if you're
watching this, every week, we
have a moderator page
linked off of our
developers.google.live show
page, where you can ask
questions ahead of time in case
you can't attend live or
would rather just
type them out.
JAN KLEINERT: OK, it
looks like we have
six questions here.
We went ahead and added in
some responses to some of
these ahead of time, but we'll
go through each of them as
much as we have time
for anyway.
I'll take the first one,
and then we can
trade off if you want.
So the first one is actually
related to ScriptDb, and it's
kind of similar to what we
were just talking about.
So is there any to save large
spreadsheets to ScriptDb,
something like 13 times
10,000 cells?
So using the method from the
documentation, that exceeds
the expiration time
for the script.
And by saving the spreadsheet
into one big object, it throws
a data storage error.
So I'm not entirely sure which
specific method from the
documentation you're
referring to here.
One thing that would help you
probably if you are not
already using it, is there is a
save batch method that will
do this more efficiently than if
you were just doing Save in
a loop on all the individual
records.
Now, doing that could
still run into that
execution time limit.
So what you can do there
is you could set
some sort of chunking.
So you can say, I'm just going
to do 1,000 records at a time
or whatever you find is going to
be a safe number that will
allow you get it done
within six minutes.
And then set some
sort of flag.
You can use script properties
for this to say, I got through
row whatever.
And then pick up from there
and have your script keep
going until all the data
is in the database.
Additionally, I was speaking to
one of the engineers about
this this morning.
And they're still doing some
more work that should actually
solve the issue that you're
getting with the data storage
error when you try to save
one gigantic object.
There's definitely some work we
are doing behind the scenes
there to make that work better
and work more consistently
with these really, really large
objects that have a lot
of attributes on them.
So in the, hopefully, near
future, that should be a
smoother option for you
to use as well.
ERIC KOLEDA: But now, the power
of ScriptDb, I think,
really comes from its querying
abilities, where you can say,
give me all the records that
match this or match that.
But if you have one giant
object, you lose that.
So I think you're going to want
to look towards to doing
lots of individual, like maybe
one row is one object in
ScriptDb instead of
one giant object.
JAN KLEINERT: So combining save
batch with chunking if
you still need it is probably
the recommended
way to go for now.
ERIC KOLEDA: The next question
we have here is
this one here, right?
JAN KLEINERT: Yes.
ERIC KOLEDA: So I have an HTML
table, and I want to sort the
table by clicking the
column headings.
How can I do this with something
like jQuery's
library table sort,
or sort table.
I don't see anywhere I can call
the library in a folder.
Or is there a different
method?
So you've already looked
into this a little bit.
JAN KLEINERT: Yeah, actually.
So if I understood the question
correctly, I looked
at the table sorter library.
And if you go to that page, you
can download the ZIP file
that has all the related files
that you need, the JavaScript
and everything else.
While it's true that in any
Apps Script project, you
cannot just stick the JavaScript
and the CSS files
in there and then reference
them, you
have a couple options.
So if you have somewhere you
would want to maybe host the
JavaScript files--
I was thinking you could
possibly even do it as an
attachment in Google Sites as
one kind of quick and dirty
way of doing it.
And then you can reference in
the script file, you could do
source equals and then point to
the URL of where you have
that file posted, even if it
is as a Sites attachment.
That's one option.
The other would be, if it's
not too terribly much code
that it makes you go crazy to
paste it all in, you can
inline that code from
the library
just into your scripts.
So in your HTML file in Apps
Script, you can just open up a
script tag, paste in all of that
library, and then get on
with your coding.
So those are a couple options.
I have been hearing some
requests from people who want
to be able to include other
types of files and other
assets within their Apps
Script project.
If that's something that you
would prefer, then be sure to
use that in the issue tracker so
we can get a sense for how
many people are looking for that
sort of functionality.
ERIC KOLEDA: One other thing I
was going to say about the
scripts is that the way that the
HTML service and the apps
that are [INAUDIBLE] it work is
it uses a technology called
Caja, which kind of inspects
and modifies your HTML and
JavaScript to make sure that
nothing fishy is going on.
So not every script you find in
the world is going to work
with Caja straight
off the bat.
Caja will go in there,
poke around.
And if it's doing anything that
is dangerous, it could
potential remove that part of
the code, and it will block it
from working.
So for libraries and jQuery
libraries, jQuery itself is
supported by Caja.
They have verified that.
It's a popular library.
But for a lot of derivative
plug-in libraries, if those
haven't been explicitly tested
with Caja, they may not work,
and you'll have to do
some testing there.
JAN KLEINERT: And if you want to
get a sense of that without
having to write your script
first there, if you search for
Caja Playground, there is an
easy tool you can use to check
and see if something will cajole
properly or not so that
you can save yourself a little
trouble up front.
ERIC KOLEDA: Want to
take the next one?
JAN KLEINERT: Oh, sure.
ERIC KOLEDA: You were going
to answer it anyhow.
JAN KLEINERT: So I have a UI
form that's pulling in a list
of students from a sheet.
So I've coded it to loop one
at a time and add it to the
drop-down list.
If I have over 300 students,
it'll take 20 seconds.
Help.
So someone else has actually
added in a comment here, which
I'm going to read through.
Oh, and look, this is actually
a good suggestion here.
So one of the best ways to solve
this is to load the list
of the students into a cache.
So we have a cache service.
Things like this would make
sense for this, especially if
your list of students is not
going to be changing a lot on
the fly like from any one use
of the app to another.
So you can pull in this list of
students, save it using the
cache service for as long as
you choose to save it.
I think the default is
35 minutes, maybe?
ERIC KOLEDA: It's something
like that.
But yeah., you can even specify
it down to the second.
JAN KLEINERT: Yeah.
Or even up to six
hours, I think.
And then that could be much,
much faster on subsequent
accesses to that list
of students.
So it would take a little bit of
time for the first time you
pull it from the spreadsheet.
And instead of looping one at
a time, make sure basically,
that you pull it from the
spreadsheet using getValues
instead of a loop where you're
doing getValue, and that will
be much, much faster too.
And that should help you out.
The other option here, they
were saying to maybe store
those records in ScriptDb
instead of spreadsheets.
That may save you
some time, too.
I think it is generally somewhat
faster to pull things
from ScriptDb than to pull
from spreadsheet cells.
So for 300 records, you probably
aren't going to get a
huge difference, but I would say
cache service is the way
to go with this.
ERIC KOLEDA: So the next one
we have in here, is there a
way to apply query to sheets in
a spreadsheet when I join
two tables?
So I'm not entirely clear
on what this means.
I know there is a query function
built into Google
spreadsheets that allows you
to look over a range and
filter them down.
And Apps Script does
have the ability to
set formulas in cells.
So you could use Apps Script
to build these
formulas for you.
However, you can'y natively call
spreadsheet functions in
Apps Script.
So you can't call in your
code the query method.
What you could do is set that
formula into a cell, but you
ca't actually call it and
get the result back.
But a thing that we've talked
about before with data
options, there's a lot of
different ways to store data,
get data, merge data, encode.
So there are a lot of
possibilities to go about it.
It depends on what you
are looking for.
JAN KLEINERT: I would say for
this one, if we are not
totally understanding what you
are asking for, post this on
Stack Overflow with some example
code of what you're
trying to do.
And we or someone else
can probably
help you find a solution.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
JAN KLEINERT: So there's an
XLS file in Google Drive.
We need to convert it
automatically to a spreadsheet
by Apps Script or else by
a Chrome extension.
So I posted a link
to some manual
instructions for doing this.
I think if you right-click in
Drive on one of these files,
and there's the option to
basically turn it into a
related Google document.
I don't believe, and correct me
if you can think of a way
of doing this, but I don't
think we have a way of
directly doing this
in Apps Script.
We kind of have a way of getting
data from a Google
spreadsheet into some other
formats, such as a PDF, but we
don't have a way today of going
the opposite direction.
So that would make a great
feature request.
So please do add it in the issue
tracker, which you can
get to from our documentation.
ERIC KOLEDA: We've got
some new ones here.
So we have, how do you change
text in the text box without
reloading the UI?
So I'm assuming this is
the UI app, as your
answer here is addressed.
It is possible to do this using
client handlers, even
server handlers to a degree.
So when you're using the UI app,
essentially, what you're
doing is you're modifying it
in your script and then
returning that app back again,
whether it began to do that or
in the handler class.
And if you are using a server
handler, there is a trip to
the server, some calculation
takes place, and then the data
is updated on the client.
Even so, it's not a full-page
refresh as you would see maybe
in other [INAUDIBLE] apps.
But if you use client handlers,
it's even faster,
because there's no round
trip the server
that would take place.
So as the sample code that Jan
posted here, you can actually
do some SetText in a client
handler to modify
some of the text box.
So that's something you might
look into for a super speedy
text box modification.
JAN KLEINERT: Right.
And [INAUDIBLE], client handlers
won't necessarily
work on every single type of
widget, but they will work on
quite a few of them.
ERIC KOLEDA: And they don't
have every option.
JAN KLEINERT: Right.
ERIC KOLEDA: But if you want to
do some simple things like
she said here about making
some things visible or
invisible, changing some style
properties I think, changing
the text in this
case, those are
possible in client handlers.
JAN KLEINERT: And we have
one last question here.
So why aren't you using
a Chromebook?
So fair question.
My Chromebook is at my desk.
And actually, you can't see
this, but if I were to turn
the camera around, you would
see we've got a couple
Chromebooks set up
in here too.
So we use lots of different
computers.
Fair question.
Maybe next week we'll have
a Chromebook set up here.
Actually, we will.
I am getting a nod.
We are going to have
a Chromebook set
up here next week.
JOSH: Well, wait, wait, wait.
I have an incredibly important
question now.
How do I go about getting
one of those stickers?
JAN KLEINERT: Oh my gosh.
If I could just tell you how
many people ask me that.
And I don't know the answer.
JOSH: I bet.
JAN KLEINERT: I can't even find
another one of these.
I don't know where
they come from.
So unfortunately, I don't
know how to get more.
But if I ever find out,
I will let you
know in a future hangout.
JOSH: Please do.
JAN KLEINERT: OK.
I should just take
the sticker away
because it's too tempting.
JOSH: I'm wondering if
it would peel off.
JAN KLEINERT: Not well.
And once it peels
off, it's done.
JOSH: It is fantastic.
JAN KLEINERT: Thanks.
ERIC KOLEDA: So we've had a
number of people join the
hangout while we've been going
through the moderator.
In the couple of minutes we have
left, does anyone else
who's live here want
to ask a question?
AUDIENCE: Ah, you know what?
I just realized it's at
11 o'clock, not 11:30.
That explains why you're
just about done.
Hope it was a great hangout.
Actually, I do have
a question.
It was about issue tracker and
stack overflow, and how do you
prioritize those in terms--
I noticed like on issue
tracker, I've been on.
And Jan, thank you.
I saw that you triaged
a couple of things
that I put on there.
How do you decide, because I
noticed there is a lot of
things on issue tracker that
don't actually have any sort
of response from anyone.
How do you decide what to
respond to and what not to
respond to?
JAN KLEINERT: So the goal of the
issue tracker is, the goal
is for us to get to every
single issue on there.
Sometimes it may take longer for
some issues than others,
but once we set something to
triage, or feedback requested
state, it means that we've
either tried to take action on
it but we need more information,
or we've raised
it internally.
That's basically what the
triage status means.
If something's still in new
status, we probably have
looked at it, and we just
haven't yet figured out where
we need to, or how we need
to, raise it internally.
And then some issues where it
turns out something might not
be feasible for us to fix,
either now or in the near
future, we may close something
out and state that and maybe
give you a workaround instead.
AUDIENCE: That makes sense.
I was just wondering though,
because it seemed like back a
ways, there were some issues
that didn't actually have
anything, going back
quite a ways.
That's what I was just kind of
wondering about was some of
those older ones that maybe
are in back awhile, and
recognizing you have a difficult
time, lots of
information flowing at you.
But--
ERIC KOLEDA: Well, if you've
been on some of those really
old issues, I have
actually started.
Every day, we kind of handle
all of the new
stuff that comes in.
But also, kind of as another
project, gone back in time and
made sure that anything that
fell through the cracks gets
an answer now.
So we've been on some
of those older ones.
I've been replying
to them, too.
So I think eventually, we're
going to meet in the middle.
And everything will be either
triaged or feedback requested
or something else.
AUDIENCE: Or fresh, right?
And I understand it's
not the same day.
I was just kind of curious
about that.
And then I guess the other
little question is sort of
subsequent.
So once you have triaged it,
do you have a framework for
prioritizing and deciding
which enhancement--
defects, obviously, you decide
how effective is it.
But in terms of enhancements,
how do you decide?
What's your process?
So you're Developer Relations,
so you've got this enhancement
that you think looks
interesting.
What's your internal process
for taking that back to the
engineers and deciding
how important is it?
Where does it fall in
the whole framework?
JAN KLEINERT: That's
a good question.
So there's a few parts to it.
One of them I can definitely
tell you is the number of
stars on that issue tracker.
So every time somebody wants to
follow an issue, they can
star it, and we can see
the number of stars.
And that is a good indicator of
interest to us for how many
people are looking for a
particular type of feature.
Other ones may already
fall into some road
map that we've defined.
And so we're like, oh, we're
definitely already
planning to do that.
But for ones where it's like,
oh, well, that's a great idea.
Let's get an understanding for
how many people are looking
for this type of functionality,
the stars in
the tracker is one way
that we do that.
And the products getting ready
to appear at Google and for
Apps Script has a tough time,
because there are way more
great ideas than I think
there are hours
in the day to implement.
So I think we do a great job.
The team does a great job here
of trying to figure out what
is most important to to people
externally, what's going to
get a lot of good work done,
what's going to enable great
new uses of Apps Script.
AUDIENCE: What's the mission
of Google Apps Script?
JAN KLEINERT: So it's actually
kind of a twofold thing.
So one is to allow you to
extend what you can do.
And I'm talking fast because
we're actually a little over
time, but I want to wrap up
your question for you.
So one is it allow you as a
developer to really easily
code and extend what you can
do with Google products,
specifically a lot of the Google
Apps products, and make
them more useful to you
and kind of tie all
those services together.
Another is just to make it easy
for anybody to build code
in the browser.
So you're building this stuff.
You're just coding
in the browser.
It runs on Google servers.
And today, you can build
web apps really
easily and deploy them.
You don't have to worry
about hosting.
So it's all about making a
simple way for you to do all
of these things.
And on that note, we are
quite a bit over time.
So thank you, everybody.
AUDIENCE: Sorry about that.
JAN KLEINERT: No
problem at all.
It's a good question, and we'll
see you all next week.
And next week, I think we're
going to be at 4:30 PM,
eastern time, from
a Chromebook.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
JAN KLEINERT: All right.
AUDIENCE: Bye.
JAN KLEINERT: Bye.